The things that we see, the things that we
face.
No one can do this alone.
It's a really hard job.
Both of my sons are heroes.
Central City, the name's Kid Flash!
Yo, Hey!
My Suit goes there!
That is a conundrum.
I don't know what the future holds
but we'll face it together, hand in hand.
Hey Youtubers happy 2017.
New flash footage so let's break it down there
is a new round of the flash ring giveaway.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video be sure
to click that bell to enable alerts so you
don't miss anything, just because that clip
is kind of janky a couple minutes after this
uploads I'll add subtitles to make a little
bit easier, but number 10 Caitlin telling
Barry he can't do it alone, she's talking
about savitar mostly like what's happening
right now but really it's a generality like
you cannot take everyone's problems on by
yourself you need the team.
Team flash, so that's a big U-turn from where
she was a couple episodes ago when she was
becoming killer Frost she was the one that
was pushing the team away.
So the whole idea here is that team flash
is like the most important thing them staying
together working together so obviously a big
part of the drama the back half of the season
is in people pushing other people away but
just to borrow flash funds people going rogue
he worked really hard in the first half of
the season, to give everybody their own problems.
Like Cisco's dealing with the grief from the
death of his brother.
So Caitlin is becoming killer Frost.
Yes to do with that even Joe has his own stuff
going on besides his fat like you know most
of his story revolves around Iris.
And now Wally that he's on the show but he
also has socio-so even he has his own stuff
going on.
So those things start to become really big
and pull people away from the group in the
rest of the group has to come together to
bring them back into the fold.
That was kind of what the killer Frost episode
was about like Caitlin was freaking out not
telling everyone keeping secrets and it started
to drive her away from the group that they
were able to bring her back.
So now she's the one giving that speech to
Barry you can't do this by yourself, so number
nine next little bit Barry voiceover talking
to Wally and Joe both explaining that protecting
Iris is the new mission that he's mostly talking
to Wally when he saying this.
You have all these powers, but what you need
to remember is is that Iris is the mission,
so it sounds like what he's telling Iris and
the other trailer like about the future about
her dying.
So we might come clean and tell Wally but
based on the other footage in the trailer
it sound like Wally doesn't know and that's
why he's so happy because he pry be super
bummed out if he knew his sister was going
to die in the future to, so this is like teacher
Barry trying to push Wally in the direction
that he wants them to go without giving him
all the information which of course is going
to fail miserably if you learn anything from
watching arrow is that keeping secrets from
the group always blows up in your face.
So also, to lose this background to that the
Joe part where Joe was talking to him about
still being part of his family being his son
Barry again in his grief is like slowly being
driven away from the group.
Although largely it's his own fault because
you know Wally is like a real big deal the
season so Joe being his biological father
is going into overdrive trying to make up
for lost time Barry's feeling like the odd
man out is driving him further away from the
group Joe, just reminding him in this footage
hey you're part of the family are both my
sons number eight.
Next little bit Wally capturing plunder in
front of what looks like a group of cheerleaders
this, but it might be out of order, but it
just seems like he's basking in the glory
of being a newly minted speedster like I just
got a brand-new car some to tear it up all
over town.
This is so much fun.
So it definitely sounds like he doesn't care
about Iris because like Barry's walking around
with all this on his shoulders.
So we super bummed out super stressed and
Wally is just riding high because this is
all brand-new for him.
So he's like Barry back in season one right
after he got his powers having the time of
his life, to try to figure it out as having
fun which causes problems number seven because
he's not like totally thinking it through
dumps is suit like he runs and dumps is sued
in Barry spot then runs back out pacing Barry
up like hey that's my spot.
So more friction in the group you look at
Cisco's like I don't I don't know what to
do this is awkward Caitlin probably has a
similar look on her face.
Like when you see two of your other friends
start to fight and you don't really know how
to handle it.
But just remember this is like the beginning
of the back half of the season.
This is all drama that I think will help catalyzed
team flash before they're able to take down
savitar the whole idea is that you can't defeat's
savitar by yourself you need the family.
But this stuff happening right now is like
the hurdles that they have to jump through
and it's gonna be way bigger than this is
not like just Wally and just Barry in just
Jay Garrick are going to be able to defeat's
savitar, so we'll talk about that in the second
because it involves the other flashes of the
multi-verse which is really big deal, but
number six Cisco and kid flash bonding more
than Barry and Cisco bonding.
So Cisco forgave Barry for sort of causing
flashpoint in seemingly killing his brother
like he blamed Barry you calls flashpoint.
My brother was alive.
Now he said.
So then over the course of the four night
crossover Cisco because some of his own problems.
So he sort of forgave Barry like we may the
dominators threat that much worse.
So now I understand why Barry did what he
did.
He was trying to make things better when he
actually end up making things worse.
So I don't think there's any way that Cisco
would ever like.
Just like push Barry out but I do think that
Wally's excitement is sort of infectious and
Barry's being like a huge bummer right now.
So sometimes within a friend group if one
of your friends as being like a super bummer.
You just don't pay quite as much attention
to them.
So I think that's all that's going on right
here, but number five little bit bigger plunders
robbery that lands him on team flash is radar
that sort of like the big mission of episode
10 like the big new villain like hey look
is a new flash road so on the surface is just
a simple bank robbery.
They capture him they stick them in prison.
But then you remember the flash forward and
episode nine, were they given the name dropped
that news broadcast he's getting ready to
stand trial.
The reason I think they included that name
dropped is just to sort of give you a bookend
for like where this endpoint is just like
help you chart it in time mentally.
This is the beginning.
So now you know the beginning and the end
of this new sort of like self close time loop
that Barry is going to try and mess with,
so all the stuff in between is what he's gonna
try and change.
So remember he's gonna try and go back to
the future to change it again that's gonna
be like one of the first things that he tries
to do so when we go back or however many times
we go back to that future point just listen
for the broadcast and see if any of that changes
with the plunder talk soleplate right here
this is the initial version child care.
So when we go back see if they replay that
in the changes in the way that the future
newspaper that we saw all across the first
couple of seasons change.
Like they brought it back during the four
night crossover like the time vault is back
the just little tricks they use to help let
you know that things have changed, even if
characters on screen don't necessarily say
that.
So just be looking for clues when they reach
red old ground like coming back to the same
point but somehow things are different just
a little bit the number for another big WTF
Iris West walking up to a gun barrel looking
like she's daring this person to shooter.
This doesn't look like plunder.
So it looks like it happened somewhere else
in the episode but the promo had that text
of flashes over the screen powers are no powers
the hero lies within.
So this is just meant to be a heroic moment
for Iris stopping this person from doing whatever
he's doing this might have something to do
with the plunder bank robbery the plunder
usually works alone, so we'll see where it
leads.
But you have the idea that she knows that
she's going to die how she going to choose
to face that so as you can at the like find
a way to be a hero even though she doesn't
have powers.
So the using a lot of metaphors these trailers,
but number three then Barry tells her will
face it together in a different scene which
is kind of in opposition to what they're saying
in the rest of the footage in the trailer,
we know that Barry tells her that she's going
to die.
So she probably starts to freak out this is
probably him, just trying to reassure her
will face it together but you know from the
other footage in the trailer that he slowly
pushing the team away.
That's why they have to remind him we have
to do this together.
Otherwise, the team wouldn't need to have
that conversation with Barry.
But again all of this doing things as a family
doing things together is mostly speaking about
the savitar stuff in the short-term in the
broader sense is just the idea that you know
Barry being a God doesn't need to take all
of the worlds problems on by himself.
So that's one of the things that he still
hasn't really figured out in the last couple
of seasons he's learned a bunch of new tricks.
He's learned what not to do when he goes back
in time thanks to Jay Garrick just like you
inking about of the time stream hell no kid.
Don't you dare try to change the past again
for like all of season two.
It was all about getting faster and faster
like using the tacky on device that he could
defeat soon, but this season the big twist
is they presented him with a problem in this
savitar conundrum that he can't solve by just
getting faster like just getting faster isn't
going to help save Iris so that's part of
the big lesson.
Yes to learn, but number two more Caitlin
stuff.
So, they've said that killer Frost is going
to be really big in the back half of the season
the producers like oh yeah we have like a
really big story coming for her.
So because her big thing is in trying to hide
her abilities trying to suppress them in makes
sense that in ignoring that problem.
It'll eventually become so bad that she can't
ignore it anymore.
So we know every time she uses her powers
she becomes a little more killer Frost and
you can't reverse it is that can be season
for Kayla she just gonna walk around being
super clammed up all the time.
I would love that I love the look of killer
Frost they changed a little bit each season,
but even if they did want to do that Harrison
wells has a device for masking your appearance.
So if she wanted to she could actually walk
around as normal Caitlin even if she were
full-blown killer Frost.
So there's still a number of directions they
could take this see you guys can let me know
in the comments do you actually think she'll
go full-blown killer Frost again before the
end of the season, but the number one big
deal in this is actually a really huge deal
from the comics is is the idea of the other
flashes of the multi-verse in the idea of
the larger flash family so when you're talking
about the flash family are mostly talking
about the good speedsters on earth one we
have Barry you have Jay Garrick now we have
Wally and Jesse quick.
So for now they are the flash family probably
pretty powerful if they were to ever work
together.
But then you have the idea of the other flashes
of the multi-verse and even though they're
not literally family they all share the sacred
bond that makes them family so what I'm hoping
they get to it is a bit of a did a great Morstan
twist is that you have this multi-verse Justice
league idea that the not can it do multi-verse
Justice league think about multi-verse team
flash working together to take down savitar
because Jay Garrick as he tells like the legend,
of savitar, he just goes around two different
worlds sending Harold and then killing you
whatever speedster challenges and there so
now that Barry is powerful enough savitar
has sensed him through the speed force in
his like oh here's a threat that I need to
get rid of.
So he sends Dr. alchemy and now you have flash
versus savitar, so this is it just happening
on earth one this is happened on countless
other earths of the multi-verse and because
savitar exists in this pure energy state he
doesn't really age so he can just do this
for the rest of time.
So what you do when you have a bunch of flashes
that by themselves are not powerful enough
to take down this super God of speed while
you have to team up multi-verse flash family
so that this image right here of them all
working together.
This is from great Morstan's multi-verse of
the but even if you just look at Geoff John's
old flash rebirth.
You know towards the end they all team up
there all running together you get this image
I think were working towards something like
this at the end of the season so let me know
in the comments do you think that we're going
to see a team flash like flash family versus
savitar by the end of the season because they
keep saying in this trailer that you can't
do it by yourself.
Meaning you have to do with the team and what
better team is there.
Then the flash family but what can happen
later tonight is I have a new arrow Prometheus
video so I'll announce the flash ring giveaway
winner in that what you guys wait for that
to post you can click here to watch the other
flash trailer that I posted and you can click
here for the arrow trailer that you so much
watching everybody let's high five I'll see
you guys tonight!